I think was about three some odd years
ago when he came on this program sat
here in person in person and now his hit
show Dave on FXX
season 1 finale is tomorrow night at
airs the next day streams the next day
on Hulu where the streaming numbers have
been off the charts over 5 million more
per episode and the man himself little
Dicky right here on the Rich Eisen Shou
right right here on the rich has to show
how are you bud how you been I'm better
for talking to you the number of people
when we was at episode 4 right yeah
we're an episode for us we're co-stars
with their work to get we're co-stars
with Dave Burdick a little dickie ho
well you know what it's very rare that I
ever screamed the words out that you and
and Jeff Schaffer the creator of the
show asked me to scream out and you know
so I don't know I kind of stepped out of
my shell a little bit on that one Dave
boys did a perfect job we kept saying
thank God for rich because he really did
the perfect thing for that montage I
appreciate that
how is this all worked out for you man
this has been quite something I'm wonder
what it's like from your perspective
well honestly it's been hard for me to
like really soak it in because only like
Saturday did I hand in the season finale
like and up until like Saturday I just
been working on every episode like like
almost up until the week before the
episode comes out so it's like I've been
kind of be still really working hard on
it and only like the past three days do
I feel like a free man and like able to
like soak it all in but I'm very happy
that you know even a guy I'm a huge
movie fan and like so my favorite shows
ever I didn't even find out about until
like their second or third season you
know what I mean so it is kind of weird
like that so I'm very happy that people
are already watching early okay so how
real to what this is in your life this
is a fictionalized version but tell me
what's real on this it's definitely like
you know some things are like word for
word exactly how they happen some things
are like loosely based some things are
like totally fictitious it's like very
odd it's kind of a hodgepodge but like
you know I don't know if you want to
talk about something that's specific
like
was born with a penis that needed
surgery my height my hype man get it
really doesn't bipolar disorder like
there's like a lot of things I could say
that's real uh-huh and things that I
could say that's kind of based on
something that really happened and the
things that could be like that never
happened but man that would be funny if
it did so Gaeta in in the show is your
real life hype man right and and yeah so
I how how did you know he could act Dave
uh you know I had a hunch like if you
meet this guy you you know anyone who
made seems like well who the heck is
that guy he's like a character you know
like he's very dynamic as a person yes
and he almost carries himself like he is
famous before even being famous like
people kind of thought he was saying
like just because of how he was so he's
just like you know you just know people
there
I've never liked it either so it's like
how did I know I could ask I just knew I
was the charismatic person that you know
I was capable and I felt the same way
about gave it well I mean you knew you
could act I mean how does one become a
little Dicky the story is pretty
impressive I mean the real-life story
about how you start it off and start it
out for those who may not know can you
recount how you did your first video in
first couple videos yeah my number one
dream and I thought how can I get
noticed for being funny and like I
didn't know anybody in the entertainment
industry go like hand a script to I
didn't know how to make like a team like
I seemed like a sketch or something but
I had the software and I can do to make
music and I always kind of rap growing
up and I didn't see many people doing
funny rap music so I started rapping
just to be noticed for like to be a
comedian and the laughing just got
better and better and like it caught up
to the comedy side of it too were like
I'm like you know I've become like in my
mind I feel like I'm one of the best
rappers in the world and that my first
video online and I like I've been
working on this for like two years
without showing anybody and that song
was ready to the first video out and the
second I posted it went to like the all
the it went viral I got a million views
in the first four hours so that day were
always kind of be the best day of my
life as I feel like it's the day that I
like really learned I am who I thought I
was and listen he was
so how did but the way you shot it
though didn't you like walk up to
people's doors and say can I use your
house use your boat use your you know
didn't you yeah that was another video
that looking about a year after that
first video save that money and that was
my first like big names feel I call the
first videos I did I didn't even know
anybody that made music so I had to like
go online and steal other rappers beats
and like make songs over like a Drake
Peter like you know what I mean like
stuff that I don't even own the rights
to them I didn't even monetize and I
finally like to what producers could
send me beats and like that saved that
money some you just reference is one of
my first original songs and my first big
mainstream moment like the first time I
put out was like great Internet II but
save that money is like on the radio I'm
like yeah I pretty much made a whole
music video for completely free I just
like talking people into letting me use
their things
yeah I'm Fetty WAPs Snoop Dogg Chris
Brown I mean ariana grande Justin Bieber
they all follow correct in your career
Shawn Mendes brain yeah you know I've
left a few out yeah there's a lot I
guess no I'm fortunate enough to wear
like that you know they're like all just
like normal people so when I meet that I
think I just like means like you know
establish a good rapport relationship
and we stand touching them if I need
then what I saw I think they all trust
my creative vision so I'm just very
lucky that everyone I guess seemingly
believed in me yes sure do little Dickey
here on the Rich Eisen show and yet we
still have not been able to pull off the
caper that I was trying to cultivate a
few years ago cuz you're a die-hard
Philadelphia sports fan and at the time
Andy Reed had just left for the Kansas
City Chiefs trying to get you know
trying to get you to do a rap song and
video with aunty Reed called times yours
because that's how he always starts his
press conference you know what it's I'm
not gonna give it up I think it's too
damn good I think it's too damn good he
still every press conference
period starts with him giving an update
on injuries and then looks at the at the
gathered remember the media and say
times yours every single one of them
he's been doing it and now he's won a
Super Bowl I was so happy when he won
like nothing no other team winning has
made me that happy because not even your
own Philadelphia Eagles a couple years
ago
no no other team not on Eagles team
women I see brought me back Chile
because of Andy reading yeah I think he
some of the best coaches ever and I
don't know might take away from Andy
they does not want a failure and so
inácio this one was like oh my god that
man check this relevant to like over a
decade what do you think of the the
current Eagles situation I don't know
how much you've been paying attention to
it since you said you've been just
focused on editing your show and putting
it all together but I don't know I mean
are you talking about Jalen Hurd from a
second round about what you make of that
one yeah you know here's the realities I
wanted CD lamps so it's like that was my
main goal going into it and then add to
the fact that the Cowboys got it it's
like a double whammy and then I'm like
yeah I don't understand I don't get it
like and like I really don't even the
rationale somehow II just like I just I
don't think he can it's like what is the
like the best-case scenario here I don't
know what it is what is it Carson once
gets hurt and then you have a good
backup like because I just don't I mean
which is I guess I also I don't know
it's it's frustrating because I feel
like we have more needs but and like
even if he does put them out 12 to 15
plays a game or whatever and they run a
second one pick on the gadget player I
don't know but maybe they know something
I don't think Wow how about this let's
have a conversation here about this
because that's the way the Eagles won
their Super Bowl was when c-couldn't
against the bell and that the backup was
so good you got the biggest football
moment of your entire life and now here
they are to try and make sure that if it
happens again they're prepared for it
and Eagles fans are wondering what's
their malfunction I don't think Phelan
Hertz is even gonna beat out Nate
shutouts or the back of course so it's
like this guy's not even gonna be the
backup quarterback this year and I like
me like I think he's I think he is a
good backup quarterback and I believe in
him
so then you're thinking like if we get
into the back up this year it's like and
I support win now mode I think we're
trying to win right now by the way that
is an that is a little Dicky hot take
that Jalen hurts won't even beat out
Nate's son felt that would be a problem
don't you think I think they love Nate I
think they really love Nate I'm not even
kidding I think they believe in for like
four or five years he got hurt last year
but I even people were loving him I
think I might see when the precinct I'm
very impressed
so I guess before I let you go where do
you stand on the subject of embiid and
Simmons being able to play together I
think they can they're both too
competitive and too good and elite like
they're both like people always say like
Oh Ben you know he's never going to
shoot it's like even if and in a
conservative mind space if Bensons
doesn't start shooting jump shots
consistently for another five years like
think about that not next year not five
years from now he's still only 28 years
old at that point and he's like she
noted me in so it's like he's so young
that I don't know what the fuss is about
it's like and he's gonna start shooting
eventually and there's no chip on their
shoulder like winners I believe and they
were lucky bounce away from maybe
beating the champions last year so I
think they're in a good spot they did
more shooters
and I don't think it's a I don't know
the issue is Mb Dan Simmons I think it's
just like the pieces around them and if
they're not ready yet and they're not
ready yet but they're going to be ready
and in three years from now they're both
going to be like 26 27 years old so you
don't think it's an issue of them
meshing each other with each other
because that's the way that was a
conversation before the season got
postponed for the moment that was the
whole conversation I don't think it's an
issue I really don't care about just
lock down the fenders and you know they
need other pieces that complement them
but I don't think those two guys like I
should feel like a young Shaq and Penny
so before I let you go the season finale
tomorrow night other than clearly
special guest appearance by Nate
sun-filled what should we expect on
tomorrow night's season finale well
Dickie I expected like I could give you
like 10 million
as to what happens even if he watched
every episode never even come close to
guessing it if I told you no idea his
and it's I think it's one of the most
you know insane revolutionary things
that's ever been put on television I
think it's like my masterpiece well it's
just the first season you can't you
can't peek too soon you can't do that no
I agree but it's my masterpiece to the
stage that's gonna be I don't know if
this is going to be it's going to go
down as a classic episode of television
for sure a classic episode of television
on FXX tomorrow night 10:00 Eastern Time
thanks for joining thanks for dick
calling it anytime let's get you back on
soon okay be well kiddies that's Dave
bird aka little Dickie here on the Rich
Eisen show hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here